[Musique]
c'est au palais de la source que le 10
de la Réunion a présenté ce mardi 28
mars les nouveaux engins et matériels
opérationnels mis à leur disposition 2
millions 600 000 euros d'investissement
ont été réalisés vous savez que tout est
évolution et les équipements évoluent
les équipements de sécurité évoluent
nous devons mettre à disposition des
professionnels de la Réunion les
meilleurs équipements qu'on peut trouver
sur le marché c'est du matériel européen
et ce matériel est bien a fait ses
preuves et ici quand vous avez toutes
ces espaces de forêt c'est shankan c'est
immeubles d'habitation ces zones
urbanisées nous devons bien sûr avoir
des professionnels engagés mais nous
devons aussi disposer des meilleurs
matériels c'est ce que nous faisons en
allant chercher sur le marché européen
ce qui se fait de meilleur au service
des sapeurs-pompiers de la Réunion si
nouveau véhicules viennent renouveler le
parc du 10 et augmenter sa capacité
opérationnelle les pompiers bénéficient
également de nouvelles tenues pour
augmenter leur sécurité
en termes de couleurs on passe du bleu
marine rouge donc plus visible sur
intervention avec des nouvelles
signalétiques fluo et des tours de
puissantes qui nous permettent de
repérer éventuellement un pompier qui
serait tombé dans un bâtiment pour
pouvoir le récupérer rapidement et le
sortir pour éviter que le son sa
situation grave c'est une nouvelle tenue
donc composé de trois couches donc il y
en a une ici une couche de polyamide est
à l'intérieur et notre couche de
protection en dessous donc 3 une
nouvelle tenue trois couches entre les
deux couches on a donc une circulation
d'air qui permet donc de maintenir une
température acceptable pour les pompiers
qui vont au feu tout en augmentant la
protection contre la chaleur radiante
donc on pourrait souffrir les pompiers
qui seraient en intervention
enfin le style c'est désormais équipé de
tablettes numériques un outil innovant
qui permet un transfert sécurisé des
données entre les pompiers le Samu et
les centres hospitaliers afin
d'améliorer la prise en charge des
victimes
[Musique]